how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have some really awesome
news to break down talking about
Wolverine in the MCU and Deadpool in the
MCU as well we actually have quite a bit
of Deadpool news today Ryan Reynolds has
recently made some more comments about
Deadpool joining the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for Deadpool 3 and we have news
about how Marvel could be developing a
Wolverine Weapon X Disney Plus project
and we'll talk about how Marvel Studios
has actually been setting this up for
over 10 years Marvel has wanted the
x-men in the MCU for some time now in
fact they have left many different
Easter eggs all throughout the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they expected the
Disney foxtail to come through at some
point they didn't know that it was going
to take about 10 years since when they
planned on it but the rights to all of
the mutants and x-men are back at Disney
and Marvel Studios and now the x-men can
come into the MCU including Wolverine so
we'll talk about the Wolverine and
Weapon X project that is said to be in
development right now and all of the
Easter eggs that Marvel's put for the
Weapon X project and then talk about
Deadpool 3 in the MCU if you're new be
sure to subscribe for all the Marvel
content and my Funko pop Iron Man
giveaway ends in a few days all you have
to do to enter subscribe like the video
and leave a comment about the video down
below so many of you who have been
following for some time now are probably
aware of who Roger Wardell is before
Avengers and game came out and I'm
talking six months before Avengers and
game came out Roger bordelles Twitter
accounts started to leak things about
the film and every single thing that he
leaked ended up being 100% true so a
very credible source and he seemingly
has a new account where he dropped a ton
of news for us in a tweet he said Weapon
X Disney Plus show planned as a pre
sequel to the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier it will focus not only on
Logan's backstory but also the other
members of the weapon Plus program as
well now the Weapon X program is a
program in which the government takes
mutants and other individuals and
experiments on them in order to enhance
them and all of their abilities the
Weapon X program is responsible for many
different characters in the MCU
Wolverine and
Poole are just two of them Wolverine is
often referred to as Weapon X because
Wolverine was the tenth experiment done
by the program but the first person that
was ever experimented on in the first
weapon that was made by the program was
the one and only Captain America the
super soldier program that did
experiments on Steve Rogers and made him
into Captain America was essentially the
Weapon X and weapon plus programs just a
different and eration of them the
program has been shut down and opened
again under different titles several
times but they're all essentially the
same and Captain America is weapon
number one and Wolverine is weapon ten
now before we dive into all of the many
easter eggs in the MCU about Wolverine
and the Weapon X program we should
clarify that the new Wolverine that is
going to be coming to the MCU is not
going to be huge Ackman
recently Hugh Jackman was asked in an
interview that now that Marvel and
Disney owned the rights to the x-men
again would he come back to play
Wolverine and unfortunately he said
honestly if it was seven years ago and
this would have happened he would have
totally done it but for now he's left
the party so they're definitely going to
cast a new Wolverine even though the MCU
wanted Hugh Jackman's Wolverine for a
very long time and they've been planting
a lot of Easter eggs and setups for him
and now a new Wolverine is coming with
the mutants and the x-men and this was
announced by Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige at San Diego comic-con of
2019 and remember in an interview after
San Diego comic-con he was asked what he
meant by mutants and he said that
mutants and x-men are interchangeable
they mean the same thing and then he
said that Deadpool was also a mutant as
well so he grouped him in with Deadpool
meaning that Deadpool is coming and
Deadpool is part of the Weapon X program
that's how he was made so depending on
what Marvel and Disney want to do with
Deadpool we could see him show up in a
Disney Plus series but of course he will
have to be a toned-down version but it
definitely could be a segue of how to
introduce Deadpool to the MCU it just
sort of depends on whether or not
they're going to stick with the Fox
origin story for Deadpool or create
their own new one but more on Deadpool
in just a bit let's talk about how
Marvel has planted the Weapon X program
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe since
the very beginning of the birth of the
MCU
not a lot of people realize that Marvel
Studios has been planning on the x-men
in
turning the MCU since the very beginning
of the first film Ironman
we have a deleted scene that was never
shown in the movie and could never be
shown to us until Disney officially
owned the rights to those Fox x-men
characters however once the Disney Fox
deal was complete Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios showed us
this clip demo accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough I have to deal with a spoiled
brat doesn't play well with others
and wants to keep all his toys to
himself so this is a deleted scene from
Iron Man the original Iron Man film and
this is the scene that they literally
wanted to use as the post-credits scene
but the rights didn't work out and they
couldn't but the fact is they were
planning on the mutants being a part of
the MCU and then we go to the Incredible
Hulk where Thunderbolt Ross explains
biotech force enhancement the Super
Soldier program he says it's an
oversimplification but yes it is the
Super Soldier program just a different
iteration of it and it's the same
research that made the Hulk when Ross
reveals the Super Soldier Serum that
he's been working on he reveals these
tanks and on these tanks you can clearly
see that it says weapons Plus program
and again it's the same program just a
different iteration but this is
particularly important because it
actually establishes in the MCU a
relationship between Hulk and a
Wolverine essentially Banner was working
on the weapons Plus program he just
didn't really know because Thunderbolt
Ross kept it a secret from him and not
to mention that Mark Ruffalo has been
teasing us with a Hulk verse 12 rein
project in fact he said he would like to
see that happen four times in public
interviews to bring Wolverine in and put
him in the same film as the Hulk would
make perfect sense since people want
more of the Hult and savage Hulk not
professor Hulk and Mark Ruffalo wants it
as well and since the rights are at
Universal currently they have to do a
air-quote team-up film end of air quotes
and I say that because if they do this
they'll actually be fighting not teaming
up so the leak says that this weapon
Plus program is going to be revealed and
take place before the events of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series and
if you think about it it makes perfect
sense Thunderbolt Ross secretly has been
developing this weapon Plus program and
it's the same program that is the Super
Soldier program which
we know is going to come into play in
the series because we know that the new
Captain America is going to be given a
Super Soldier Serum and this was
actually confirmed in a recent screening
where they showed footage of the first
episode of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series in this episode they
showed Bucky going to visit Zemo in
prison and Zemo tries to reactivate
Bucky as the Winter Soldier but it
doesn't work because sure he got rid of
the programming in his brain after Civil
War and before infinity war after this
Bucky walks up to Zemo and he tells him
that Thunderbolt Ross has restarted the
weapons Plus program so it's finally
coming full circle we saw Thunderbolt
Ross start the program in the Incredible
Hulk and now it's finally coming back
into the MCU and that's where this new
report of a Weapon X Disney Plus program
comes into play we're gonna see all the
experiments that this program did on
Logan
aka Wolverine and all of the other
experiments they did on other people as
well side note this almost guarantees
that the Red Hulk is coming because the
weapons Plus program is announced to be
brought back by Ross and in the Black
Widow leaked photos we can tell Ross is
in bad shape and this is most likely due
to him testing serums on himself which
is how he becomes Red Hulk in the comics
so after 10 years the weapons Plus
program is finally coming to light and
again one part of that could be Deadpool
now there's been a lot of talk about
Deadpool 3 in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe recently specifically because
Ryan Reynolds came out in an interview
and basically said I don't know if
Deadpool 3 is going to happen and then
Deadpool creator Rob Liefeld came out
and said that it's Marvel's fault that
we don't have a third Deadpool film yet
however all of this is very easily
explained
first of all Rob Liefeld stating that
it's Marvel's fault that there hasn't
been a Deadpool 3 yet and may not be a
Deadpool 3 is not accurate the reality
of the situation is that Rob Liefeld
really isn't going to be involved with
Deadpool 3 so he's not really in the
know about the project because he's not
going to be working on it because the
truth of the matter is Deadpool 3 is
basically confirmed for the MCU despite
whatever is going around right now there
is all the evidence in the world that
there is going to be a Deadpool 3 and
that it's already being worked on at
Marvel Studios first of all there is a
production grid going around right now
that confirms a Deadpool project is in
the war
at marvel studios and it lists Kevin
Feige and Ryan Reynolds as co-producers
and that was one of Ryan's big things he
wanted to really be in charge of
Deadpool Deadpool 3 he originally wanted
to be completely in control over but
he's playing with the big dogs over at
Marvel Studios now so Kevin Feige is
definitely going to be involved then you
have the fact that the writers for
Deadpool 1 and Deadpool 2 confirmed
several times that they are working on a
rated-r Deadpool over at Marvel Studios
and then Bob Iger former CEO of Disney
himself even stated that they are going
to be working on a r-rated Deadpool and
then we have Ryan Reynolds on a national
television show when asked about
Deadpool 3 he said yeah we're working on
it right now with the whole team we're
over at Marvel now which is like the big
leads all of a sudden it's kind of crazy
so yeah we're working on it
literal confirmation from Ryan Reynolds
himself now what has happened since as
that things have gotten a little bit
more official Marvel Studios probably
now has more concrete plans for Deadpool
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and as
Ryan Reynolds mentioned before he's in
the big leagues now and of course Marvel
Studios likes everything that they're
doing to be very very private so now he
can't just go out and say yeah Deadpool
3 it's coming it's about to be here etc
etc because Marvel Studios has a
standard and he has to live up to that
standard which of course is no problem
as we've seen right now he is simply
playing it cool and even just the other
day he was on The Tonight Show Starring
Jimmy Fallon and he said I see infinite
possibility and either version of
Deadpool were to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think it would be
explosive and amazing and what a sandbox
to play in
if Deadpool continued to get to just do
his own thing and be his own thing
also just infinite possibilities so this
is classic play Nakul he talks about how
awesome and explosive it's going to be
if Deadpool gets to be in the MCU but
then adds a little disclaimer at the end
but also if Deadpool continues to do his
own thing and not be in the MCU it's
fine to but really this is just kind of
I don't want to give anything away so
Deadpool 3 is absolutely happening it's
been confirmed by several different
sources directly from Marvel and it
seems like the Weapon X program just may
be what brings him into the
see you so my question to you is would
you like to see Deadpool's origin
rewritten for the MCU and possibly
appear in the Weapon X Disney Plus
program if that comes true or would you
like for everything to stay the same and
simply enter the MCU currently as he is
right now be sure to let me know what
you think in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Deadpool 3 and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for live
updates on everything you can follow me
on Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fluff